[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast and
in this episode I'm sat down with Antony
Wilmot and I just want to talk and pick
his brain about some of the good some of
the bad and how you can be a successful
property investor in 2020
so Anthony what do you think is the
biggest reason people fail in this
business I think a lot of time when
people get into property they see the
successes a little for people and try to
gauge their benchmark against that yeah
I know when I got into property that's
what I was doing quite a lot and then I
was starting to resent my own journey
and starting to resent other people
because I wasn't having the same so you
had the same success do you don't think
that benchmarking your success is a good
thing because it's like that's possible
if they can do it I can do it I think
it's I think it's a great thing but I
think ultimately people need to realize
that your journey is yours yeah and you
need to plan it your way you know so
what I started doing was planning out my
own journey my own goals and what I
wanted to achieve because then like you
say if I see people's successes yeah
then I can they're kissing right that's
my next goal that's what I'm striving
towards yeah rather than saying that's
an excuse for me to not do something no
that's an excuse for me to say do you
know what this didn't work for me nearly
mmm I think it's an interesting one
because like my journey it took me four
years to become financially independent
and that was really hard for yes like we
dick usually hard and at the time people
saw that and were like oh my gosh that's
so fast you didn't in four years I
started 17 I was 21 it was like a
miraculous story to the point where I
was then asked to go and speak on stages
and share it and it was like I was the
freaky weird kid that managed to become
financially free for years for starting
from a teenager but I feel like I've
changed
I've set the bar so high now because now
so many of my students how long did it
take you to become financially for it so
I from when I actually joined Academy
yeah I hit my financial freedom figure
by the end of December and sorry
November I joined the Academy so join
the Academy in November and I hit my
financial freedom figure by the end of
December right which is ridiculous yeah
and you started that same year yeah so I
started
I came to the first crash course in May
so it already made the arrangements to
start I set my business up at that point
and then but I had six months yeah so
before you you did the DfE in the summer
so that's when you advanced between
started so with it way less than a year
see that's a lot faster than I did it
and there's people that have done it
faster than me and then I don't do my
financial freedom challenges what people
forget is that's me doing a financial
freedom challenge with all of my
knowledge with all of my experience with
all of my skills with all my confidence
cuz I've done it a million times before
so I can do it real fast but I think
whilst that's inspiring for many people
and the benchmark is being set really
high and then other people have been
able to stand on the shoulders of giants
and and and and it's inspiring and it's
empowering to some people has the
opposite effect as some people actually
find it demoralizing and disempowering
because they compare themselves yeah and
I think that's really important because
you know I made arrangements to get in
well I decided against property January
2018 and December was when I became
financially free but to start with
before I came to any formal training or
courses I was comparing myself to people
you know I was being quite resentful of
what other people were doing because I
didn't really know what I was doing
didn't have the right training in that
support well I think once I got all them
things in place and once I knew exactly
how to achieve it everything just
happened very quickly because I knew
what I was doing I knew how to do it and
then all the people I was just using
them as leverage to help me become
successful so people that were then
successful with me you know like you
said standing on the shoulders of giants
I was using their experiences to help me
get to all got to quicker yeah you're
like one of the most supportive people
on the academy like literally you just
meet with other Academy members wanting
nothing in return
giving people advice and you regularly
post on the group's and say things like
hey anyone exists as a support and
normally people say that there's an
agenda there's an ulterior motive like
they're saying it because then they want
to sell them a deal or or whatever but
but with you it's it's so genuine it's
from such a position of genuinely one of
the people to succeed where did that
come from because I I know where I came
from
and I know when I struggled to start
with like I said that point between
January and when I came to my first
crash course I knew how difficult it was
for me because I didn't know what to do
so you know all these people have
invested in their education all these
people making that step to try and
become financially you don't do people
that have not invested in cell phones
you know and that's it you know somebody
they need to invest and I get that you
know whether it's with you whether it's
somebody asked investment in education
czar big it's a big choice to make to
invest in your education to become
financially independent so those people
have already made the big leap for me so
I'll give them the time they need and
sometimes it's a case of do you know
what you needed a lot more training and
you need to go this way you need to go
that way so my goal in property is it's
just what great houses on the market
because I've lived in a crappy property
so I know what they're like yeah yeah so
I want to put great houses on the market
so if everybody has the same skills that
I have there's six hundred and sixty
thousand empty homes in the UK there's
not competition for me because there's
plenty of people going out there and
doing the same putting great properties
on the market yeah and ultimately will
just help the overall economy because
well when you've got a no one a big part
of your strategy now is you buy
properties that are really rundown that
no one else wants to touch and then you
renovate them and then you refinance
them but like a lot of people have god
like that's not combatant people say
that landlords are greedy or that
they're competing with all the
first-time buyers but actually the
definition of entrepreneurship is
finding a problem and fixing it not
competing with other people is finding
when people aren't doing James Caan says
follow the masses and do the opposite
and I think that's you know
yes copy entrepreneurs for sure copy me
for sure but then ultimately as you
become more successful once you started
once you do the first few deals you kind
of want to find your own thing find your
own niche yeah where people aren't
necessarily doing again something that
where you can bring tremendous value and
then just push that for all it's worth
what do you think yeah I agree with that
and that's the thing I mean when I hear
people say that you know landlords are
coming in and being greedy I don't think
that's true because you know as a nation
we've become a nation of renter's so
there's more people out there wanting to
rent properties now than there are by
them so and you know there's this is
entrepreneurs
their property investors that do flips
of strategies so they are providing for
first-time buyers because ultimately
people can just walk into a new house
then that somebody's refurbed and then
they're people that are doing the buyer
refurbished refinance rent strategy
these are the people that are providing
for you know where councils can't
provide for houses they're providing for
people that just want to rent a nice
house in an area because for them at the
time where they're building their family
or they're building their career that's
exactly the way they want to go so yeah
I think exactly there's this that that's
why they're doing it you've been
speaking a lot recently and I've been
coaching you a bit talk to me about that
so obviously myself and Ricky and some
of their Academy members came on to some
speaker training with you because we
wanted to better ourselves we wanted to
be able to share the knowledge that
we've got in the right way to help
people taking that information and learn
it what do you want to be a speaker
because I want to inspire people the way
that you and all those speakers have
inspired me because I've been to many
seminars and sometimes you sit there and
you're nodding off and you're going to
sleep but when somebody like yourself
comes on with the right energy and the
right movements it you know it allows me
to take in information backs and that's
how I work and I taking the information
by listening and watching and doing the
people what's this book if you've got
stuff have you got anything juicy so
this is just my so I bought this journal
recently because I want to keep because
I found I'm getting so busy now with
speaker training and coming to events a
lot and then helping people that I
wasn't managing my time very well yeah
so I look to get a journal because I
want to obviously put my career goals
into perspective I want to put plans for
the day so it's not just a case of right
this is a to-do list of the day every
day you know it's got inspiring quotes
in there it also allows me to reflect on
things that have happened in the day
because I think it is important too many
people go through today and think well I
didn't really achieve anything today or
that was a rubbish day so every day I
take the time to reflect on what's
happened subscribe you know what
successes have I had today
what could I improve on today and that
allows me then to just close that day
down and then move on to the next one
tell me about your experience the very
first time
on stage of the crash course so you know
what the very first time I got on stage
at the crash course I was actually
terrified so I remember you saying to me
if you know if you carry on the way you
go and you keep being successful and
because I'd become financially free you
said we've got the first ever crash
course in London thousand people I'd
like to invite you on stage and I
thought this will be a breeze I'll come
and get on stage and tell people I've
done and I go up there and stood and
looked out to these crowd of people and
my mouth went dry and I thought I don't
really know what to say and it was I was
very lucky that you're there because
obviously you ask questions and you
coach me through it but how they have
just had the opportunity to get up and
just sit just start talking to people
yeah it really gave me that feeling of I
respect what speakers do because to be
able to get off and present and to talk
to people you know that abundance of
people not knowing how they're going to
react and not knowing how they're going
to perceive you as a person it gave me a
new respect for it I think the reason
that I wanted you to be a speaker as
well is because you've been there done
that got the t-shirt and you and I know
that you did it really fast but now you
you know you've been financially free
for quite a long time now you've been in
property for how long so I quit my job
January 2019
okay so just every just every year ago
yeah came to DfE May 2018 couple years
that you first got started
yeah so you've been there difficulty
shirt gone a bit got a bit of experience
and sometimes people act really almost
smug you know I've been in property 20
years and it's like yeah but you suck
and you've got three by two let's that
don't make any money and you say you've
got 20 years experience but really have
one years experience photographed 20
times
so I'd rather learn from someone like
Anthony that's got a nice portfolio
that's very profitable with a diverse
mix of rent to SAS HMOs be are ours so
that's the first thing second thing is
the fact that your story is so powerful
because when you when you when you meet
you in a very different place tell me
about that so one of the reasons why I
wanted to get into property in the first
place was because you know I was having
a bit of a tough time you followed the
you followed the status quo
I followed the system which
one who to follow go out get a good job
get good grades you know work hard buy a
house you know get married to have
children so this was the this was the
route I was going down I was working
hard
most of the thing about that listen to
this because you followed this plan you
followed the government the school
education system the banks you followed
their plan and this is their plan I'm
gonna go through each each category of
people persons think and describe their
agenda government they want to have
complete control over you and everything
and they need you poor and dependent to
do this the super-rich they want
financial literacy save for themselves
so they can have all the money banks
they want all the money or your money so
that they can invest in themselves
education system they're not allowed to
teach anything that's not in the
government appointed curriculum the
media they sell bad news stories to get
more views but ultimately control by the
government the general public are mostly
slaves to the system but looking forward
to retirement age 65 and then there's me
rich financially free and showing
thousands of others exactly how to do
the same in order to leave a legacy and
change the system I think that's it and
I think the problem is what the you know
following that government system is they
force it on you the minute you lose
something you have nothing left well see
you lost your partner say yeah and then
potentially was gonna lose my house that
put all my money into buying yeah at the
same time because of the economy
I potentially was gonna get made
redundant for my job yeah so all of a
sudden this big system that had worked
towards getting this great job getting
this great house working on it you know
meant nothing you know and my university
degree you know although it taught me
some great life skills now wasn't really
helping me we're talking ten years down
the line from when I achieved that
degree yeah so then all that happens is
if I if you know if I did lose my job at
that point or even then people that were
then applying to replace me in my job
yeah their skills and qualifications you
know in my skills and qualifications
didn't matter for nothing it's a case of
whoever was better for the job so my
university degree 10 years down
didn't didn't help me at all you know
well you a manager I was a manager at
department manager at Sainsbury's you
know good job great department great
store and all sudden everything starts
moving around and your whole life gets
changed around from and and that was
just it like I just couldn't deal with
it anymore
what was your lowest point my lowest
point was you know so I suffered with
depression because of you know things go
off and down up and down for me and you
know I had had nobody around you know so
because my partner left and it I'd moved
to another another another town it's all
my friends you know she took them with
her so then I was stuck in this town on
my own with no friends and my family you
know quite far away from me so I didn't
really know what to do and you know when
you're left in your own in that
situation and it's just you then your
thoughts take over and that's when your
mind starts to kick in and that's when
it starts to take over from you and this
is one of the reasons why I help people
so much now because I know how much when
your mind turns against you you've got
nothing yeah because that's the thing
that keeps you going
isolation bad thing exactly and you know
I was isolated and isolated myself as
well so even though my family are great
and supportive I'd made a conscious
decision to isolate myself so funny
because when you came to the DfE you was
so not you didn't seem like that in that
place I don't know where you were at the
thing is is you know nine times out of
ten most people can't point somebody out
with depression or anxiety in a crowd
yeah because we put a front on you know
and and I can spot them a mile away I
can see these I got them that's the part
of the problem until you've been Nancy
you've been in that situation you'll
never understand what it's like but I
are warm to you and I remember at the
deal finding extravaganza I was like we
were chatting a lot and I was working
with you on the coaching core I called
you out and asked you to come and to
come with us because I knew that you
were going to be successful but then the
pot the pot sometimes I see potential in
people and this is Mark the problem
hangout I'll see so much potentially
someone but then when they then give up
it like breaks my heart because I've
always pictured
at this point of success I visualize it
and I'm like yes and I see it for them
but sometimes they need to see for
themselves yeah you know and I think you
did I think you saw it for yourself I
think that's it that's the tough part is
when people don't see it for themselves
they'll never strive for it and they'll
hit the first hurdle and the eyes not
pause it's not for me so what are some
of the biggest hurdles that you've had
over the last six months I think some of
the biggest hurdles for me are are
really around the mindset piece really
around just dealing with with you know
overcoming problems that things have
come along because when you you know
when you make phone calls to agents and
you know their shoot you down or they
can be quite vicious sometimes on the
phonetic you probably because the agents
that we're speaking with have received
phone calls from people that have
watched my youtube videos attempted to
do the do but not done it with the
correct knowledge and then the agents
been pissed off and then when people
like you or iPhone they just love this
before Oh serious investors people that
a deal sources but then they buy the
deal and that happens but anyone to sell
it to and then waste our time so we end
up picking the slack up for that and at
times people have even said to me you
know Sammy well you shouldn't even teach
YouTube you know don't do it because
people you know people just attempt and
fail but ultimately because of people
like you that watch the YouTube videos
and then came to the crash course and
attend it properly you know gives me
motivation to keep going but yeah I know
there's cause you're talking about but
that that can that can really put you
down and when you come off the phone you
think ah maybe I don't want to do this
anymore
yeah and you know it's about celebrating
negative successes yeah and I think the
biggest thing I've taken away from the
last year or so that I've been doing
this is to celebrate the successes you
know so every week I I must reflect on
what's happened and celebrate the little
successes because you can be too hard on
yourself I mean when we when we started
speaker training both Ricky and I every
time we come off the stage so hard on
ourselves but then you can end up it can
be the reverse because if you've got to
go back on the stage then you're not
putting your best foot forward and
actually your disservice and the people
there in the room
and that's not fair on them people then
because they've come to see the best
that they can get yeah I own a great I
think that you want to be the best you
can be but don't you don't wanna be so
hauling stuff you beat yourself up yeah
but I think you've been great with the
speaking I mean always like I mean when
you first did you first like fifteen
minute piece on stage and you're
completely on your own remember that yes
what happened so I had planned it out
and again like I said when you get off
on the stage there it kind of takes over
and and you feel like you can't make any
moves but really there's those things
that you know the people just want to
take the information in and I had a
moment where I froze and I didn't really
know what to do because there was nobody
like you they're asking me questions and
yet on the stage with you on your I
forgot my content but I you know it just
took me a second to think
actually I've delivered so much content
to them already that lets give him a
second to take in the information that
they've learned which to gave me that
breathing time yeah to review what I was
doing and to come back quite strong that
was only like four months ago yeah oh
you've come on I got some great feedback
from that from the people that took him
for the information as well so it just
goes to prove how hard you can be on
yourself and actually you know they've
they've took the information in really
well but it's just about now I just want
it great to be but now you've almost
become addicted to speaking on stage I
love it and inspiring people you know
what the message is that yet when you
come off the stage you know and you'll
have this now the people saying that oh
my gosh you know you you've changed my
life I've just done a deal because of
your you know that must be really really
liberating and satisfying for you I get
lots of messages like that now saying
really loved hearing you speak really
love the piece that you presented I
thought it was great
can't believe you've ever been only
doing this a short period of time and
then but that leads on to longer lasting
relationships yeah because again these
are all people that have invested in
their education these are all people
that are on the journey as well yeah so
you know it just allows me to then then
help them a little bit further because I
know that actually you really liked my
piece then that means that that's the
strategy you want to go with and again
like I said that helps me serve my
purpose you've also written a book yes
in collaboration with a few other people
I polished
let me see let me see this let me see
this making property compliance easy
talk to me about why you wrote
well why we wrote this book so we got
together and the things that are in this
book have taken me 15 months to find out
some of the information in that and so
they're because they're the really
little things that people don't know
about and you know so it might be the
little details about how to set up a
joint venture how you can raise
different types of finance whether it be
through joint ventures and what them
agreements look like and you know it's
it's all the little things that and
they're very specific questions and
what's good about the book is some of
the things that are in there if you were
to present them in a room for the people
only 20-30 percent of the room might be
interested in parts of it yeah so the
books great because it's there it's a
quick tool to go back to you know oh I'm
looking at yeah setting up a but we're
talking you talk about well there's
there's tax there's compliance in every
aspect deal sourcing rent to rent option
agreements joint venture raising finance
just buying a house tenants setting up
the business yes phenomenal guides and I
think that I used to get so many
questions about this sort of stuff so
it's just great that you've helped write
this this book and you had good feedback
yeah I've had some good feedback so sent
the first couple of copies to parents
friends and family they've really
enjoyed it and then the last couple
events I had to have two people come up
to me and say I've read your book really
enjoyed it and some great content in
there that's good it's just it just
makes a quick guide for people to go to
from a branding perspective there's
nothing better than writing a book I
must admit I really enjoyed writing it
but when you write a book that only do
serve people but you also position
yourself as as an authority in a subject
so it just it just kind of makes you the
go-to person which I think from a
branding perspective is just insane and
and and I'm really glad that that I've
managed to help some people become
authors Hanuman's James Armstrong
yourself I mean you've been getting some
serious high profile people I know I've
been connecting you as well with some
product with some cool people don't
leave it by that so then what's that
messages in what do you think when you
see my name problem what's that you're
like oh yeah I see the message Samuel
leads and it's
like referrals I think are great why
who's who's this gonna be this time but
it's always someone place it's really
great I mean we've had three high
profile footballers that are into us and
these are people that you know for them
they've they've made their money they've
you know and now they're trying to be
clever with it and trying to invest for
their future and again I really respect
that because it's like look we haven't
got time we're still busy with work at
their work you know to to invest in
education but we want to find somebody
that is the go-to person on specific
strategy to help us find the right
properties to invest because we want to
make our money go further yeah and
they're great people to work with
because they get it they understand
they've seen all your content they've
yes they'll come to me for some a bit of
mentoring or orbiter guidance but then
they haven't got the time to go and view
properties and stuff so I'll pass them
to you because I'm at the time I like to
be honest but you're you're you you've
got so many deals coming out in your
ears and sometimes I think this person
could really connect well with Antony or
James or Ricky or whoever and I love to
pass referrals that way and you know
anything about what's that message for
me you know it's always good news always
goodness it's never bad news you get a
message from me it's always good news so
what you plants over the over 2020 so
this year James and I are focusing on
some bigger development so now I have
enough properties where it rented rents
buy reverbs and lease options that are
making me enough money for that
continued cashflow each month and trying
to focus on doing bigger deals because
I'm achieve my goal quicker so this is
why we focused on the pub that we're
looking to do because we want to focus
on trying to look at like these that
tear to towns where the town's gone
quite low the footfall in the town's
really low and take empty buildings in
there if we can and turn them from
commercial to residential because then
it provides housing for people and it
also drive footfall into the town as
well yes so again it just helps
everything then there's there's no worse
luck or position than being in a
desperate place and when your unit house
isn't trying to do deals and sell the
awesome and you're desperate you're
really motivated to get financially free
then suddenly you're a motivated
investor when you want to be dealing
with motivated sellers yeah and it flips
it around and it makes it even harder so
you
being a position of complete abundance
financial freedom but and some people at
your stages that are must really retire
now but you're saying no no no I'm
coming from a position of abundance and
now I'm gonna scale this thing and do
some big deals from a position of I want
to I want to leave a legacy I want to
inspire people I want to make more money
give more money and be more I think
that's a really good place so I'm super
excited
piece of advice final piece of advice
for someone listening to this who's
where you were two years ago who's
wanting to become successful in property
what would you say I think the final
piece of advice for me is you need to
have very clear goals about what you
want to achieve and if it's you need to
because you're looking to build a little
big legacy or even if you're just trying
to become as wealthy as possible you
need to streamline your expenses to
start with because you've got to be
realistic about what you want to achieve
and then focus on setting very clear
goals you know refreshing them every
month or so and then using that to
couple with your education and you'll
learn in whether it be through books
videos or coming to courses and get
yourself in the right place at the right
time and networking with as many people
as you can because you know ultimately
when you start out it's about building
that network of people and knowledge and
once you build that and use that to
couple with your goals you'll go very
far that's great and if people want to
see you they'll probably be able to see
you at crash course because you pretty
much go to every crash course which is
insane
awesome thanks so much for your time bro
thank you and people appreciated it guys
if you appreciated the content if you
enjoyed listening to Anthony you can
connect with him on social media you can
come and see us at the crash courses and
hangout become successful but please
don't forget to smash the like button if
you're watching on YouTube and if you're
watching on podcasts how about go and
check us out and leave us a review on
the podcast show appreciate you love you
hope to see you soon and god bless
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]